He broke out of his crisis!
I was sitting here for minutes watching Gengar.
I'm not even kidding you guys.
Hold on.
Wait, I took a screenshot.
Where did I save it?
Here.
This is not even a minute ago.
This is what he looked like.
Not even a minute ago.
This is what Gengar was doing.
Oh, poor guy.
Moe-moe boo!
Oka-irina-san-imase, go-shijin-sama, ojo-sama.
Hello, everybody.
He broke out of his funk.
If he can, you can too.
Moe-moe-boo!
Welcome in, everybody.
Welcome in.
It's time to live the dream.
Tomodachi life.
The full game.
Come on!
Hello Minto and I boost like you!
I'm excited to see what you come up with today.
I'm making halogen and lauri of my island.
It's a struggle but we're getting there.
I believe in you.
Why is Gengar dressed like an avocado again?
It really gives him like such a booty doesn't it?
What are they both doing?
I don't know why Frogbert looks like he's...
Uh, I hope he's not doing anything on the yard.
Koyu-chan!
You know, that's...
Oh, Sugi, don't you?
$5,000, let's go!
In Japan, isn't it called?
It's like, wait, it's like, wait.
It's like, wait, Tomodachi Collection in Japan.
And then it's like, instead of living the dream, it's like,
Tano Shisei Katsu or something.
Kyomomito-chan daiskii!
Kōyu-chan daiski daiski da-yō!
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yippee, my telenovela is on!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, hello!
Welcome back!
Thank you so much for two months, Chair!
Anastasia, thank you!
Phil, thank you!
Sorry, Phil, thank you.
Golden Fool, thank you.
I had much work to do today.
So my voice might be a little exhausted.
But I finished so much of my work today.
A huge, a huge bulk of work that I was doing.
I finished today.
Yippee!
So there's still a little bit left, but the big bulk is
done.
Yes, yes.
Happy, happy, yippee, yippee, nice seeing my Yoshi back from
my break, welcome back, thank you, first time I've been able
to catch a stream in forever, welcome back, thanks, can't
wait for Hal again to meet Raiden, wait, Raiden would be
great, oh shoot, I have too many mees I want to make, well
big boss and Oslo are making that on the back, I have a
small, A small list of...
Eight me's that I would like to create.
Maybe I should have done some offline.
Oh, geez.
I'm ready for peak.
Oh, no.
That's a whole stream right there.
That's how I feel.
it's fun to watch that part too right i will try not to
spend hours in character creation face now thank you so
happy to see you playing this this game is my new obsession
it's so fun making weird little dudes and watching i know
there's just something so simplistic and fun to watch right
me creation stream well i do have more tomodachi life later
this week so i if I take too much time in the character
creation.
Maybe.
What is going on with him?
He's having a rave in his head.
What is happening?
But, um, of course, myself.
Minto.
Mint Phantom.
The one and only.
Me.
I plan on putting me in the game and i want to put you guys
in as well i want to put in a little eye blue
i'm almost a year and a half old little baby thank you
frogbert is i don't know what he's doing he's doing like the
squat challenge or something the guy's got thighs of steel i
mean it kind of suits him though no because he's a frog
gengar is like frozen i made a third me and I don't remember
who it is.
I made a third me.
I can't remember who it is.
Wait, I did make Snake.
I thought I didn't make Snake.
I know I can't remember.
Mid cafes or theme cafes I should visit.
Visiting Japan in October?
Made Dreamin?
Is a good choice.
Yes, yes, yes.
He's using his style.
Where is he?
Two years old, thank you!
Hey, Dreamin'.
You could go to Zetai Ryoiki Cafe.
I like that place too.
Check the boxes.
The potato salad is good.
No, Dasko, you're thinking of at home.
That's the one we went to together.
But yes, the potato salad slaps at at home.
The one in Akihabara is a great location for main dreaming.
Actually, there's like four.
So, wait, am I right?
Or is there five?
One, two, three, four, five.
There's five.
But my favorite is the Heaven's Gate location So I've been
sadly missing your recent streams Because I'm binging anime
But now I am able to focus on my Yoshi That's so good though
Honestly it's so good if you are like You know Maybe you're
like I want to tend to my other hobbies Please do please do
oh but anyway shall we live the dream together living the
dream it's good to like stuff but don't forget to come back
you can't like the other things so much that you don't
return
it's not like I miss you or anything but wanna bet what if
Mito is our other hobbies, though, boss.
Heavens gave us the one I went to.
It was really fun.
Yeah, I think it's nice because it's a big location.
So there's lots of it's easy to get seated at.
If I am your other hobby,
who's the other hobby?
Home?
If you get the chance, you should catch up on ReZero.
The season's going to be an anime of the year contender.
No way!
Ah, they, I, I, I stopped watching after they went on that,
like, long hiatus.
Marina!
Stop sending me money.
Don't send me money.
Actually, I should, I would have sent you money.
I would commission you always, Marina.
Thank you so much for the week.
Thank you!
Don't ever send me money.
Stop!
Absolutely binging fragrant flower blooms with dignity manga
while I got my wife on the PS5 and TV in the background.
What?
Wait.
I think you misunderstood being my hobbit.
The hobbits are going to Isagard, Isagard, Isagard.
Brenny, thank you.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, I do gotta catch up on anime.
I've been, like, kind of really into my webtoons recently.
Because I, like, kind of, I got so busy, I kind of took a
break for a bit.
But recently, what have I been reading?
I was catching up on...
Oh, this one series!
Oh, my gosh!
Yep, Brittany, thank you so much for the download, Pratib!
What the heck?
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Um, um, there was this one web tune that I really liked
called Tales of the Unusual, and then they released Tales of
the Unusual 2, which are like, oh gosh, Frogbert, what's
wrong with you?
Which are, which are like, they're like kind of short
stories that are just a little bit bizarre, and so I was
like binging that.
Recently, I've binged like...
I've binged like...
90 episodes.
Like so many.
Because I found out that it'd come back and I was like,
Wait, I had no idea that they made a second one!
It came back in 2004...
No, sorry.
2024.
Mint, it's...
They're taking the hobbits to Eisengard.
You quoted it wrong.
Go away!
Actually, I can't be mean to you, Steiner, today.
Because you helped me...
You helped me with the thing.
Lance, thank you so much for the pink!
Minto has filled the hobby since I'm juggling work and self.
Aww!
Takanashi!
Wait, Kijara.
New outfit.
Oh, you are so beautiful.
Minty, you are the me woman in my head somehow.
What's that mean?
Kewawa!
I was watching your monster hunter earlier.
Your new outfit is so...
The women that you are.
I love the bangs.
You mentioned like the long, blunt bangs.
I'm also a fan of that.
I feel like we haven't talked in five years.
I'm always watching you though.
But it was like a...
I get shy chatting on people's streams.
Pian, I love you all the same and even more.
It has been a while since we've talked though.
We've been busy.
I've been busy.
I've been so busy.
But I feel like my...
After next month, Busy, well, hmm.
Hmm.
I think things will calm down a little bit, maybe.
Unless something happens.
Who knows?
Kiara just chats wherever.
I know, she's so great.
Don't jinx it.
No, I'm not going to jinx it.
Not going to jinx it.
But that's okay.
As long as I can stream, I'm happy.
So here's a minkie.
Thank you.
I know, I hope we can hang out again.
soon too.
It's been too long.
I just saw the new outfit.
Wow, wow, wow, I know.
Oh, I love me.
Kiara with like long straight hair.
Chef's kiss.
Stop thirsting over me.
Oh, sorry.
The membership, thank you.
No, please continue.
You're just too beautiful.
but no go play me again can i put you in my island i'm not
really good at making the memes though why is it showcasing
like my two like why is it showcasing these guys the two
freaks of the island i can do better i can do better we got
news we interrupt to bring you some breaking news here's
what's happening on our island what's happening there's room
for another resident on yay get strong your own welcome back
away tome inside your own in further news we're hearing that
a tnc reno home supply is likely to open once there are four
residents and two pairs of friends oh as of press time it's
unclear why the business has such strict friend requirements
but I assure you that I do not make the news I just recorded
thanks for watching thank you oh his eyes get freaky oh yes
The new fountain has a money icon over it.
Let's check it out.
Bus.
No way.
Wait, people have been throwing money into the fountain.
How do they have so much spare change?
$28.60, cha-ching, baby!
Thank you.
It looks like one or more of your residents chipped into
donate money you can spend it however you like i will they
don't play that they don't pay taxes here so they have to
throw money into the well you know just a hunch but i bet
that the happier your residents are and the more developed
your island is the more generous they'll be with their
donations can't wait to make minto minto me on my island
minto minto minto minto wait
you'll find a new donation waiting for you once a day so be
sure to stop by so you don't miss out all right what what do
we have going on oh this is telling us that we can make a
new person right yeah but before we do that i think some of
our people are a little frogbert has a problem you know
what's wrong buddy huh haven't seen you in a little while
big boss sorry buildings here on yay get strong drone
welcome back away tomen cider own sure have he dies miss
froggy wow so true walking between them would be a lot
easier if we had some paths could you don't question the
name of the island everybody it's a very the essence island
you know so you want paths what do you have in mind you
don't like feeling the grass between your toes Oh!
Whoa, he just...
He did that for me.
Okay.
Wow.
Architect.
Urban developer Frogbird over here.
Wow!
Okay.
Looks great.
Having some paths will make the island look nicer and will
help the residents get around.
Construction projects usually require payment up front, but
I know a guy who knows a guy...
Since this is the first project, it'll be free of charge.
So can we go and get started on the construction?
Oh, they give me a little sample construction.
They're like, now you're addicted to it.
And now you're gonna want to develop, develop, develop.
Mmm, free infrastructure.
Construct away!
Oh yeah, I'm on it.
Let's get going.
I want to see him in a little hat.
A little construction hat.
Oh, never mind.
All done.
Take a look whenever.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, made him happy.
I gave me money.
Wait, oh my gosh, I made money by...
What kinds of video games do you like playing?
Oh!
I like story-driven games.
Here, let me see.
Maybe I can, like, kind of move, like, here or something.
Should be good.
Wait, add text?
Eroge?
Erogey?
Grandma!
Grandma, I'm spelling it out for you!
Erogey?
Ero, yeah, we'll do Erogey.
That's so true.
Hero guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Arrow guy.
I like anime and arrow guy.
Are you purposefully messing?
I was trying to get it right.
I, too, aim to be the arrow guy.
Okay, we'll try it.
We'll try it.
Hold on.
Let's try it.
Let's try.
Let's try it like this.
Ero gay.
Oh, it's good enough.
It's good enough.
Ero gay, huh?
Maybe I can borrow one sometime.
Of course.
Frogbert, I have such esteemed tastes.
I hope he remembers that.
Oh, the toilet paper.
I forgot about this.
All right, let's go check out on Gengar as well.
But didn't you have an issue?
Oh, wait.
Snake has an issue.
Oh, no.
What's wrong?
Um.
Great to see you.
Big boss, if I'm not wrong, it's been 20 days.
20 days?
Not long?
Well, it did take a minute for the game to come out.
I've been thinking too hard.
My head feels all fuzzy inside.
Oh no, don't think.
Let me take a look.
Oh, he's got crabs.
Oh my god, crab battle!
Crab battle, crab battle!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I lost.
Oh, I didn't even know it was actually a battle.
I didn't even see the timer.
Phew!
I feel so much better now!
Crab battle!
Do I get the crab?
Maybe if I do it in time, I get the crab?
What do I say to someone who's hurt my feelings?
Oh.
Villain, have you no honor?
You won't disturb my peace.
Apologize or else.
Is that voice a side effect a fox die and must be?
Yeah, we can do liquid.
Let's be a good one.
You should say, in all caps,
liquid.
I'm interested in how this will sound.
Liquid.
Let's see, let's do...
Lick...
Oh, oops.
No, no, no, no, no.
I accidentally press back.
Lick...
Whid.
Whid!
It, it, it, it...
Maybe this will help.
Liquid
Just gotta remember what the boss taught me about CQC,
counterbalance the knife.
Quick slash retract.
Thanks for reminding us of the old boss lore.
Old lore boss.
Liquid.
Yeah, it's good enough.
All right.
I'll give it a try.
pause he sounds terrible we need to get somebody that speaks
faster on this island or i'm gonna go insane all right we
checked on our little friends let's let's get some food
welcome oh snake looks so good in the outfit oh tap water
pizza oh it's not friday i was gonna say it's pizza friday
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Oh, the...
Oh, my gosh.
Too cute.
Yum.
It's me, Bob's Burgers.
Minto.
Maumel from Apothecary Diaries has a crush on you on my
island.
Have you seen Apothecary Diaries before?
She's cute.
I know who she is, but I've never seen the show.
I've been meaning to watch it, though.
Wait, the gingham dress is too cute!
The din- Oh yeah, flashy medale.
Oh my god, the roses!
Trash can suit.
Ribbon- Wait, these are cute.
For somebody.
Wait, I have an idea who later.
everything's so cute these are the daily wait did i get the
gingham i don't think i did
wait the school uniform top way it's so good
the tennis uniform dragon costume goes hard
basic dress this one is this one is fabulous they added so
many great like little options and everything
i don't want to spend all my money on everything but i want
to add everything to my catalog you know wait who is a
gangor is now wait what are you doing yes um spin what's
that the mint kingdom is so perfect i know guess which side
the coin will land on when it stops spinning oh okay okay
what do you think it'll be tails heads or tails tails tails
tails tails huh well let's see if you're right
it's tails you win big boss i know i do i want to know who
it is in like the other regions because this is george
washington right i mean sorry gengar washington but in the
other regions i want to know congratulations you won time
for your prize go ahead pick one medium is a premium.
I could have gotten a diamond.
I could have gotten...
Wait a second.
I feel cheated.
These prizes are not worth the same.
Just I was like, oh, it's so cute.
No.
Haven't seen you in a little while.
Big boss.
Yeah, hi.
What's up?
It gets all dark and lonely and spooky.
Spooky.
Get strunger on.
Welcome back away, Tome and Ciderone.
It kind of looks like a person, like, who's...
Can we brighten the place up a bit by adding some street
lamps?
Who, like, skinned Gengar's face and, like, is wearing it.
Because the mouth is just a little...
Like...
Let's see how the street lamps look.
Whoa!
Oh!
Sure.
I think we could optimize this better, but it looks fine for
now.
It's free, right?
Nice and bright.
Now your means don't need to worry about tripping in the
dark.
Why is my boy bald?
He's not bald.
Wait, Frogbert gave me the free deal.
There's no option.
There's no option that says I spent all my money on clothes.
Gangur doesn't know a guy.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
I'm on it.
No, he doesn't know a guy that knows a guy.
Ouch.
What the heck?
There's a springy in there.
Take a look whenever.
Thank you.
Why are you and Snake not getting along?
I'm sorry.
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
Just a hypothetical.
Yeah.
If the world went dark tomorrow, what would you want the
last thing you see to be?
Just a hypothetical.
What are you planning?
What are you...
I like a TV.
A fascinating movie.
A beautiful landscape.
What is it?
Oh, is...
Oh, you can change it.
A...
Beautiful bosom.
A beautiful bosom.
I'd like to see that.
Me too, Gengar.
Me too.
Oh.
See you, buddy.
See you, see you.
No, he's still caught his Maracas.
He's playing under the streetlight.
Yeah.
Yes?
Well.
Based in real.
That's my caveat.
I think most people would agree.
What is a little...
Okay, all right.
We gotta stop getting distracted by our three guys.
We need to have more guys.
No, well, thank you so much for the tour.
Thank you.
Okay.
Sheesh.
It's funny, I had snake on my list because I forgot that I
had made him.
That's okay.
We're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna make me now.
Get it?
me.
Can I be blue?
Oh, to be blue.
All right.
I wish I were blue.
Okay.
This should be fine, this face.
Let's change it first.
Let's change the hair color.
I've seen many people's conditions of me.
Baby!
Thanks for the red!
Thank you!
Excited for your Tomodachi life shenanigans, Minto.
Thanks!
I'm making me right now!
I feel like white is too bright.
Fishing glitches.
Thank you!
Ducky!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh, I could do... Wait, the subcolor.
Oh, that's me!
That's literally me!
I do have a subcolor!
Wait, okay, let's do this not hair.
Wow.
I'm already looking sophisticated.
This is such a cute hairstyle.
Oh, so is this!
Do they have a...
Do they have...
How have people been doing my side?
My side...
My side twins.
What if I look like?
just like this though oh my gosh this looks like what's her
name from ace attorney cc thank you wait i missed more i'm
so sorry i should thank you thank you so much couple thank
you i can't stand to thank you favorite bags thank you thank
you guys for all the gifted dollia yes what if i looked like
this though what if i had three oh my god oh my god they're
Wait, it's kind of perfect.
I can draw my hair from here.
I'm looking at me.
A little more.
I'm excitable.
Nope, wrong way.
You'll be bald in the back.
I'll draw it.
My big blue eyes.
Actually, somebody that I was watching play this the other
day was, uh, I say the other day.
It might have been, was it this morning?
No, it was definitely yesterday at least.
I was watching Essential.
I was watching Marine play this and her knees look so good.
Can we make three hair mid today?
actual battle what do you mean how
does she make her knees look so good i mean i know she's
like actually really good at drawing but everybody
has like everybody is able to do such cute eyes do i have
the wrong game artist buff
She locked in with the straight tool and took two hours to
make each me.
Holy cow.
Yeah, her mees are so detailed.
I didn't see the creation process.
I was watching her play the game game.
Wait a second.
Let's see what...
Oh, I can give myself...
I have...
I have, like, three eyelashes.
Yeah.
Oh, that's cute, too.
What's...
Wait, what's the undo-do?
Oh, it takes him out.
Oh, okay.
I have no bottom lashes.
What is she looking at?
Wait.
Can I, like, make this thinner?
Oh, yeah.
You can.
Oh, wait.
There's the...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, here we go.
This is me.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, let's go back to the eye shape.
Now.
Oh, it erased everything!
Okay.
Understandable.
I think my eyes, if I, let's see.
Let's see if we do this.
Nah.
My eyes are kind of pointy, I feel.
I kind of have a pointy eyes.
It helps get rid of the nose.
That won't help.
Okay, hold on.
Back to three.
Unless we do like this.
Wait.
Can I move it down?
Gosh, the character creation is kind of crazy.
Better?
That's not what I thought it was going to look like.
Okay.
round eyes and mad pointiness with other options I
need to look in the mirror while I do this maybe I should
change my hair though because nobody will know it's me huh
mr.
yum yum thank you so much for the pie get the thank you
what's this
Yes.
Here, I'll go back to hair then.
I think I'll have to draw my hair.
My little hair dangles.
My half twins.
So what we can do is...
No.
I look like a grandma.
It's my mouth.
Oh.
Hope you have fun streaming, make some cute memes.
Thank you, Bloody Ocean, thank you.
This one's like my tooth.
Wait, do they have one with the tooth?
Maybe like that.
Oh,
oh, oh, here we go.
My tooth!
My tooth, my tooth.
Oh my gosh, a little, Yes, yes, yes.
I will make it a little bit smaller.
My petite nose.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
You look like SpongeBob.
How?
I'm not even yellow.
It's the eyes, isn't it?
Okay, let's go back to this one.
Oh, good!
Oh, good, good, good, good.
This is good.
my wait I can do my ears can't I oh wait what is this oh oh
we can do we can do our own
mature in the front party in the back I
forgot we could do the back why
am I getting like Smeagle why
am I getting Smeagle
My precious.
Oh, wouldn't it be so cool, though?
This is me when I'm getting ready for bed.
Three hairs!
Wait!
Wait.
What is happening up there?
Oh, wait!
No bangs.
This one looks like octopus, squid.
The tooth is crazy.
What are you talking about?
That's literally how I look.
What are you talking?
I think I'm going to go back to my original bangs.
Where are they?
This one looks like a surfer.
I have no glasses.
Wait, what are these?
Whoa, those are strange.
Okay, what do I do?
Can I put on lipstick?
No, my tooth is too big.
I could go for this one.
No.
My tooth is not in the middle, so...
Have you ever looked at yourself?
Oh, the dang time.
What's this?
Can't remember.
Oh, anything extra.
Uh.
No, this one.
What do you mean two sets of eyebrows?
No.
That's...
That is the...
What kind of does it?
Now I see it.
Dang it.
Why did you have to say that?
Tip for drawing.
Use your first option for bangs to prevent face clipping.
Oh no, I'm going to keep the bangs like this.
Thank you, though, Fisdom.
We can paint my hair, though.
You're a suit.
Pirate, thank you!
Why did your meat look like a turnip?
I have something to share with you all.
This might shock you.
This is literally how my hair is.
header shaped.
My iconic three hairs.
I could only grow one today.
I'm so sorry.
He
doesn't hang out with Walter White.
Admiris.
We could add him too.
Oh, is that cutie?
That's me!
Okay, let's add my hairs now.
You can do like a...
Hmm.
Okay, it's...
Can't you do like a symmetry thing?
Like you make it the same on one side as the other?
Sadly, no.
Oh, really?
No.
Okay, you can copy and paste.
Oh, okay, okay.
Ah, you're seeing the vision now!
What do you think the babies will look like?
What do you think she's going to get with?
Oops.
She's beautiful.
Thank you.
Today is AKSTF-2's birthday!
Why didn't you say anything?
AKSTF-2, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Yay, happy!
Why didn't you say anything, eh?
Shy, shy boy.
Shall I?
Little shall I?
Okay, that should be good.
Alright, I'm gonna do my triangle and then we should be
good.
I'm gonna do it in the middle of my head.
Undo.
Better.
Nice.
Oh, whoop.
Oh, they're
really...
The string.
Or else it'll fall off.
Lovely.
And like this.
Perfect.
That's me!
She looks like she likes apple juice.
Everybody loves apple juice.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
Wait, I missed a spot.
It's perfect.
Okay, now we're done.
Yeah!
Yeah, that's me, baby!
The biggest one on the island.
We can be the same height as Gengar.
Okay.
My name is Minto.
Oh wait, that's right.
Yeah.
My name is Minto.
Yes.
Grown up.
My name is Minto.
My name is...
Oh, God, it's so terrible.
My name is Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
Oh, check, don't age.
You're so right.
Don't age me.
Wait, I kind of want to...
Wait, but I don't know.
I can't age you guys, but I want to know what I would look
like as a grandma.
You're at the same height as Gengar.
Yippee!
I want to know what I would look like as a grandma.
You know?
We will age.
My name is Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
But this is Tomodachi life.
Today is April 20th, 20th, 2026.
How did she have a...
How did we create a me with a list?
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
How does this voice sound?
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 20th.
Only one tooth?
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
Oh, this is good.
My name is Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
How does this voice sound?
My name is Minto.
Hi, your pitch.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Minto.
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
So.
It's nice to meet you.
Yippee!
Uh, no.
My movement?
I'd say I'm pretty fast.
My speech?
Oh, this one's mint, though.
My energy?
Is varied.
My thinking?
I'm always serious.
And overall?
She's a quirky gal.
Sasquatch walking all over the place.
You're right.
I need to be faster.
I'm always serious.
Anybody, anybody, anybody.
Give me the whole island, baby.
Event outfits.
Oh.
Either's okay.
I don't mind.
Yay!
Ambitious!
At a glance confident.
Traits, a by the book straight talker, puts a premium on
results.
Silicon Valley Minto.
Diligent, productive, and highly efficient, equally as
skilled at planning and executing plans.
Actually, I think I am.
I think the only thing that's wrong is the confidence.
Ta-da!
Wait, Minto doesn't get a yard?
That's so messed up.
Hey, you must be big boss.
Yeah.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Minto.
I'm an ambitious achiever.
I focus on a goal and don't stop until I hit it.
Oh, yeah.
As long as I stay focused, I can do anything.
So true!
Thanks in advance for looking after me here.
I just realized what's so wrong with her is she doesn't have
my side fringe.
Oh, dang it.
That's okay.
I love you just the way that you are.
Tomodachi me, Minto.
Hello, welcome to Mambushap.
Thank you.
And Vivianzo, welcome to Mambushap.
That's what's bothering you.
Yeah, my ears are too exposed.
Embarrassing.
Wait, wait, wait, come back, come back, come back.
Do you need me?
Um, um, um.
It's hard to get things up for my help.
No, I'm weirdly good at it.
What?
What's that mean?
You're a little weirdo.
Let's give her some food.
You must be hungry.
You must want the pizza, and you'll really enjoy it.
You want that?
Yeah?
Yeah, you want that?
You want that?
Give me that?
That means a pizza!
It's gonna be her favorite thing ever.
I think that might kill her?
Yes.
Let's give her some clothes as well.
Um...
No.
We'll give the gingham dress.
Any hot dog?
Yeah, we gotta get the thing.
The hot dog too?
It was a hit!
I don't want to do the dino hood just now because whoever
Minto gets with, I want to give them the dino hood.
There she goes.
Get Gars asleep!
Oh god.
Ew, is that him snoring?
Oh, oops.
No, I meant to...
As a runner yourself, I was going to ask you for how long I
should go running today, but I think I'll start running and
never stop.
What do you mean?
Walking styles.
I want to give them...
Wait, why is it reserved?
Oh, wait.
I already have that one.
Let's do some bold.
You don't have enough warm fuzzies to get any wishes.
Wait.
Oh, I can't.
Why did you tell me that I could then?
Let's check on you.
We're gonna watch.
Oh my god, he's covered in carp!
I don't need anything but my fishing lure.
Oh.
He's really blushing about that.
Simply astounding.
This is bait!
If this is a dream, I don't want to wake up.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I won't wake you up then, buddy.
As long as I have my fishing lore, I can face anything life
throws at me.
Even fishing lore that life throws at you.
He's being baited.
I've been waiting for this.
Oh, wow.
Gengar wishing he was fishing.
No, I didn't want to wake you up.
What was that about?
I got a fishing lore.
We manifested it.
What's up?
What's happening with you and Snake?
Please explain.
The dream is real.
Something...
Minto's got a rave going on back there, so let's go check it
out.
What's happening?
It looks like Minto is frozen and killed.
I can't move!
Uh...
I'll bring someone!
You gotta get out of here.
Oh, whoops, whoops, I pressed the wrong button.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, you gotta leave.
You gotta go.
Come here.
You gotta help her.
What's going on here?
Somebody!
want my move want my move i'm being requesting halogen and
laurie from true this is gonna take a lot of elbow cream why
am i making why is everybody making halogen and laurie
about to return the favor one day anyone would have helped i
took i took him from his home wait they seem like-minded
Oh, that was it?
Oh, one of them can be overheard whispering about the
hiding.
Hiding the existence of the weak-looking elastic rope from
the world.
He's, like, lecturing her.
What's happening?
No one can know.
Oh, Gengar is blowing bubbles.
Wait, that's so cute.
His little mouth!
He really did just take Gengar's skin and plaster it over
his face now, huh?
The Kodak Briefing?
Uh-oh, Frogwort has a problem.
I mean, they were so cute!
Thank you!
Weak elastic rope gear?
What's...
What is this?
I want to be friends with Snake.
Yeah!
Great thinking!
What should we talk about?
Mowing, Matt.
A beautiful bosom.
Wait, actually, Snake would love that.
got it i'll go talk to him about a beautiful bosom all good
topics truly good evening snake do you feel like talking
about a beautiful bosom sure so Oh, fun fact about me.
When I take pictures of a beautiful bosom, they always come
out perfect.
No way, me too.
It's been a childhood dream of mine to live life surrounded
by photos of a beautiful bosom.
This can't be real.
That's a dream of mine too.
I mean, it feels like, hey, we should be friends, right?
I think we are friends now.
Minto in the background jump scare.
Yes, officer, this frog right here.
Why are we taking photos of the beautiful bosoms?
It's gonna make me as interact in new ways by adjusting what
they call each other.
For example, maybe a pair calls each other darling, but uses
a different nickname when talking with others.
Go ahead and select options if you want to try it out.
What will be snakes?
Wait, wait, wait.
David.
Hey, David.
It's too, it's too personal.
No!
I can't
do it!
I can't do it!
It's way... It's way too...
John?
Evening, David?
No!
We'll go... They have to get even closer if we want, you
know?
Wait, how do I spell Iroquois?
Iro...
There it is.
Iroquois, how goes it?
What a good reference to MGS2's camera.
Oh,
happy birthday!
Thank you for the gifted!
Hi, Nimi!
Green, woman, red.
Oh, my dachi knife!
Oh, I know!
I've been holding off watching you play because I hadn't
played myself, so...
Hope you have fun!
Thank you!
I hope you had fun!
Thank you guys for all the gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Frogbert's nickname.
We just made some...
Frogbert and Snake just became good friends because they had
a mutual dream of being surrounded by pictures of beautiful
bosoms.
Which I think everybody can relate to.
And I also made myself in the game.
What will Snake call Frogbert?
I'll let you guys decide something.
Kermit!
That's not him!
Kermi maybe wait wait what about Kermi
Kermi Kermi why is this why is this an option I know it's
not how you spell kernel but Kermi good evening Kermi yeah
it looks like our childhood dreams of being beautiful bosom
photographers have brought us together.
Looks like Kermi and I share the same hobby.
That's disturbing.
We
have expressions.
Wait, hold on.
What's the quirks?
Oh, wait, I want...
Walks without swinging arms.
Flows instead of walking?
Walks leaning forward.
I like the tiny steps.
This walking is so cursed.
We'll do tiny steps.
Tiny steps.
Yeah.
I think that's so funny.
Wait, who am I giving this to?
Yeah, floating will be for me.
You can see Nito in the background.
I feel a bit more like myself.
Uh, door.
Oh my god, they're so happy.
Holy cow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, are you gonna watch?
Alright.
What's this?
Oh, I think I can fill it up now.
Floating is great for both you and Gengar.
Yeah!
I'm at level three.
Oh my gosh, Snake is a little chair robes too much more
quirks more quirks walking style bold wait are there any
more that i can grab no i love the quirks
nice oh what's wrong what's wrong okay decu Good evening.
Good evening.
Got a sec.
I want to chat.
Of course.
Are you the competitive type?
Big boss.
I can't help but wonder.
Well, if you could pick any type of competition to
participate in, what would it be?
I'm in a blank competition.
Let's see.
Let me ask you a question.
Me is one to know all about you and the world live in.
Teach them all you can by taking time to answer their
questions.
What you teach them will spread across the island as island
lingo.
Uh oh.
Which the me's will start using in regular conversation.
You can view the island lingo at any time by pressing X and
selecting island info from the menu.
An activity I'd want to compete in is
never been able to.
I've always wanted to see what goes on in a wet t-shirt
contest, haven't you guys?
Have you?
Raise your hand if you have.
Alaskan Earpole.
I've always wanted to see what happens in a wet t-shirt
contest.
What are the criteria?
I don't know.
Well, anybody can join, probably.
What TSH IRT contest?
Oh.
Oops.
Wait, I have to fix it.
Oh, shoot.
I think I have to.
Ugh.
Oh, wait.
There it is.
There's our little dash.
No, I lost it!
It disappeared!
Oh, there it is.
What T-shirt contest?
Yeah.
Oh, I can totally see that.
Are you speaking at the podium after wet t-shirt contest to
victory?
Impressive.
How do you win?
You can use LR to move the cursor.
Oh, no way.
They're all gonna talk up- wait, what if the island has a
wet t-shirt contest?
That'd be awesome.
You don't actually have to compete to see.
I will spray with the hose next time I see you.
No, no, no!
I don't put me in.
Oh.
What's up, Ganglar?
Um.
Hey.
Got time for a game of Pixel Quiz.
Pixel Quiz?
Let's play.
Guess what the item is.
Here's your first pixelated item.
What do you think is?
Brains?
See, urchin skeleton?
The answer is.
Sea urchin skeleton Okay Next up Your second pixelated item
It looked like brains What do you think it is?
What the hell are you giving me?
Truffle mushroom The answer is Truffle mushroom And finally
The last pixelated item Minecraft charcoal What the hell is
this?
A harmonica What?
Oh it's gotta be a The correct answer is...
Tuna.
Tuna!
Yippee!
What do I win?
Congratulations, you won.
Okay, I'm going for the best prize.
Time for your prize.
Okay, we're going big or going home.
Oh!
Dance!
A techno album!
Wait, what was that?
thing the orb what was the orb instruction all right let's
make another me everybody so we have minto wait you'll be
able to add another me after tnc reno preparations to build
it are underway what i can't make another me no
Good evening.
I have to tend to my citizens.
This place doesn't really match my vibe.
Oh, okay.
Can we change up this room's look?
Sure.
Frogbear wants to renovate his home if only there was some
sort of...
Ah!
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay, soon, soon, soon.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'm on the telly.
Here's what's happening on our island.
Yeah?
Innovation Center has officially opened on Ye.
Get Strangerone.
Welcome back, away tomen's Ciderone.
The local TNC Reno home supply sells interior sets, which
can breathe new life into residents' homes.
Hopes are high that this will raise the quality of life for
island residents, or at the very least, brighten things up a
little.
Nice.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Minto, and you're up to date.
That is Minto!
What a perfect timing for a TNC Reno home supply to open up.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see it.
What would make Frog Bird happy?
New interior set will be added every Monday as this weekly
special.
Oh, and then all of the things, interior sets.
The weekly special is a music major set.
But I think Frog Bird would be happier with something like a
cabin, a log cabin.
Or a swamp.
Honeycomb.
Groovy.
Oops.
Let's go with...
Oh my god, the garage set.
The antique set.
The only one who's I watch is TN.
Like,
the blank canvas could be great too.
Marble?
Let's box.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
And I'll also buy the...
I think the log cabin would do him good.
Extremely important.
Next time snake levels up, give him an expression that makes
him start sentences with...
That is very important.
Thank you, pirate!
Blank space, the peak male living standard.
This room just screams, I want there to be no logs left for
anyone else.
Thank you very much.
Please come again.
It looks like he made a solid purchase.
Let's go back to Frogbert's house.
Frogbert.
This place doesn't really match my heart.
Wait, that is...
That is...
That is Frogbert.
He wants to burn down the forest.
Interior.
Interior crocodile alligator.
I put in a log...
cabin set for Frogbert.
This is so him.
He likes it.
To the white void.
No, no.
Somebody else can go to the white void.
It looks great now.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Renovating the interior of a home can drastically change how
it looks.
Other mees are sure to want the latest and greatest in home
renovations too.
Interior parts you replaced will be stored with your
belongings, so renovate your heart out.
I will.
Oh.
More news!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
High fives for all five.
Yay.
Get strunger on.
Welcome back away, Toma's side of road.
Hi, we're side of road.
Is now capable of sustaining five individual lives, meaning
another resident can move to the island.
And we can finally feel the basketball team.
We've also received word that a quick build amenities is
likely to open sometime after that special someone arrives.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Gengar, and you're off today.
Don't ever smirk again at me.
No.
I want to unlock everything!
Ooh!
New wishes are available!
You can wish for new interior sets.
Nice.
When I wish for a new set is granted, you'll get one as a
gift!
Thank you guys, welcome back!
This game isn't my thing, but I know how much you like it.
I hope things are...
I am having fun!
Thank you!
Breaking news, Minto is cute!
Stupid!
Oh!
World set!
Oh my gosh.
Camo, campsite.
We need this for snake.
If only we made MGS3 snake.
The doggy dog world.
Um.
Good evening.
Hello.
I want some clothes that are more stylish.
great how you are great huh well then i guess i'll keep
wearing this stylish when did snake ever care about style
huh he looks hungry though would you like some food oh wrong
thing there we go what would you like uh some green curry
yeah the tuxedo maybe okay that's better
He hated it.
He didn't like it.
There's no way.
Did you know Kermi has a lucky beautiful bosom?
He was telling me all about it.
And I think we bonded.
You don't say.
Did he show you?
Did he show you his lucky?
Beautiful push-up!
Was it the contest?
What is she doing?
Just enough is enough.
She's acting like a little Pokemon in the grass.
What are you doing in there?
Bubble blowing.
Too cute.
So cute.
Okay, um...
Uh, I do want to give more people food though.
Gengar, are you hungry?
Um, see what you've done, Minto?
I regret nothing.
Do you want...
Some tap water?
What if it's like his favorite thing ever?
Yeah!
No, he hates it.
He didn't like it.
But it's tap water!
Who else can we...
Did Frogbird eat?
I can't remember.
Did you eat?
The bottom interior with the blue sky and Doghouse reminds
me of Berry Berry Berry.
Oh my gosh, you're so right!
It is like that.
Give you a peach for your lucky beautiful bosom.
Not a water type, I guess.
Oh,
he really liked it!
Oh, yeah, of course he does.
Of course you do.
When I talked to Iroquois about a beautiful bosom, we both
got super into it.
Now we've ended up, friends.
That's beautiful.
That's so great.
Oh, are they going to talk?
Nope.
I don't lie.
What did she say?
I don't, I don't lie?
Oh.
Girl?
Are you okay?
She's so crunky.
I respect my parents.
Oh, okay.
She's just saying anything.
Those joints.
We gotta get you some vitamins or something.
I respect my parents.
I get up like sea on the bus.
Why is she saying this?
It's the scoliosis.
Hey, too close.
Too real.
Too close to home, okay?
Let's all do our exercises with me, though.
I don't waste food.
Why is she saying this?
Are you trying to convince yourself that you're a good
person?
What's going on?
Alright, let's make a new me.
Vacancy, vacancy!
Let's make you guys!
Oh, no, I didn't want to get help.
No, I don't want help.
I don't want help.
Let's make Ibu!
Boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Boo, boo, boo, boo.
Bald.
Where's the bald?
Wait.
There's gotta be in here somewhere.
Bald and beautiful.
Looks
like a genie.
Greenish color?
Yeah, probably, right?
Just a little bit.
I feel like it's too dark then, right?
Too green.
Maybe.
Did someone say bald and proud?
Bald, bald, bald, bald.
I feel like blue is, like, the bestest.
Yeah, blue is closer.
I think so, too.
That's okay.
What if I give you, like, a bit of a...
So mysterious.
Nah, we'll make you...
We'll make you...
wait wait oh no so cute whoa barcode mom i'm on the telly
no wait this is perfect oh whoops bigger
yes yes yes yes yes and for no well no no no's no no's i boo
Must be a whoosh be fellow.
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Hair color.
There we go.
Yes.
Unless you guys want a curly Q.
I mean, it's going to get hidden anyway.
Actually, this is...
This looks...
Actually.
Wait, this looks better.
That looks...
Whoops.
I meant the mouth.
Wait.
This one.
Oh, it's so cute, huh?
So cute!
Oh, wait, are there any others?
Can I give you guys a butthole mouth?
Oh, wait, it's so stinking cute.
Wait, so cute!
Can I?
No.
Wait.
Beautiful.
I can't decide between this one.
No, I think this one's cuter.
I think this one's cuter.
How will you hear my streams otherwise?
Oh, it's kind of like cat ears.
Dang it, I can't move them up anymore.
Like that.
Wait, it's so cute.
We'll keep it.
Wait.
So cute.
Alright.
Face paint.
I wish I could like move the canvas up.
You know?
Hmm.
Imagine blues.
No!
Wait.
First I'll give the maid headdress.
Oops.
You look like a little grandma wearing a bonnet.
Looking so cute.
Like a grandma wearing a bonnet.
Not that I only raised this part.
Like, like Mrs. Washington.
Martha Washington.
Minto, Minto, the ghostly made of a haunted cafe.
What is your wisdom of the day?
Don't worry what others think about you.
You're beautiful.
Just the way that you are.
Martha Washington, if she were a smurf.
Yeah.
Oh, what?
Oh, I did it again.
Oh, I missed a spy.
I just saw it.
I just realized I don't think I can do the back of your head
anymore.
So we might have to leave the curly queue.
as your uh as your little um you know spiritual part your
spiritual tail oh that's okay that
looks like that that works okay good
i think it looks good we'll
keep it like that
i think so wow I'm going to change your face shape, though.
No point.
They're not allowed to be a...
Get in there.
Yeah, I think, like, diet.
No point.
I want it to be nice and blobby.
Whiskers!
You're so right!
Okay, then we will keep it like this.
Because we got to do the whiskers.
No, I don't know.
it's too too like clean you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
very good very good oops
wait i made these ones too too too far away
He only looks like a spider because you don't see the body.
Cute and chill, Grandpa.
Oh, no, no.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah.
Whiskers are a little scraggly, but that's okay.
Do you want to be the tallest on the island?
You gotta be the...
You gotta be a blob, though.
Smallest?
My name is Aibu.
Aibu.
No.
I...
Boo.
My name is Iboo.
Yeah.
What are you?
You are just a being.
Ibu but I'll call you a little guy you're into everybody
everybody's into everybody it doesn't matter we'll do the
suit though what's your birthday when did I start ouch I
just bit my tongue when did I start streaming no
you guys are all wrong.
April 4th.
You know what?
We'll do that.
Oh, but then we miss your birthday.
April 4th.
That's when I stop streaming.
But how old do you want to be?
44 is a spooky number.
My name is Ibu.
It's nice to meet you.
All fours.
Today is April.
Oh yeah, we gotta check don't age for real for you though.
No!
I want to see you become a Grandpa too.
My name is Ibu.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Abbey.
It's nice to...
Your name...
Your name is Abbey.
Your name is...
It's nice to meet you.
My name is...
My name is Abbey.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is 8.1.
My name is Abbey.
It's nice to meet you.
Yeah.
No.
Your movement?
I'm just gonna, I'm gonna close my eyes and pick.
Oh, you're so fast.
Your speech, you guys are pretty honest.
You guys tell me that I'm, you know.
Your energy, I think you guys are varied.
And your thinking?
Maybe so chill.
Overall, normal.
I boo.
What was it something I was going to change?
I can't remember.
It's fine.
You guys are so normal.
Look at you!
You're a sociable butterfly!
Optimistic and passionate follows their instincts.
You're a go-getter.
Bold and captivating.
Their wit and charm light up a room.
It's never a dull moment when they're around.
Yeah!
That's you guys.
Your house is right next to mine.
Uh-oh.
Hey, dear.
It's nice to meet you.
My boss.
Do you want to play a game?
I'm not going to get a home that sticks behind me.
I can't understand.
I'm so normal that I'm so normal that I can't wait to start
moving here.
Gwen, hello neighbor, I am so normal if I'm in phantom.
I know you guys are, I know, I know.
Are you hungry?
You probably want a fried egg.
Yeah, I liked it.
Very good.
You think you can make a second Ibu later for shipping
purposes because Ibu's always seem to hook up IRL.
What do you mean by that?
Capiche.
I can't understand.
Oh!
He's Naruto running.
Let's go.
Our little guy.
Birthday was yesterday!
Daistra, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, what's going on here?
Oh, uh-oh.
Aibu fell!
I'll bring someone.
Here.
Minto to the rescue, everybody.
Minto to the rescue.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
You just enter Aibu's house without even... Oh god.
I actually look like that.
Are you alright?
Please help me.
So first I do this.
And then...
Oh, I think you want to something.
About to return the favor one day.
Don't worry about it.
Yay!
They are...
Acquaintances.
A lot of your fans end up becoming couples.
How is this possible?
I don't want to say a lot.
I know, like, two.
Guys, it's happening.
Look, they're talking to each other.
Wait, did you just go over to my house?
Ew, don't let them in!
Oh.
They're talking circles around each other, and they know it.
Why is it so steamy?
What's happening?
on fire.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I'm leaving.
I feel uncomfortable.
Oh, Gengar.
Um.
Thank you.
Can we get a bench around here?
Wait, what did it- oh, a bench.
Concerning your choice of voice or the iBoo's under some
witness protection program.
Thank you for the don't don't.
Oh yeah, it's like that meme where it's like nothing scares
me but that thing.
Guys, maybe she does love us.
Hey, this game is called Live in the Dream.
I don't know if you want that though.
He wants a bench?
Well, it is nice to sit and take a load off once in a while.
But how does one go about acquiring a bench?
Oh my god, I just watched a snake leave his house.
Quick build!
Oh my gosh, I think we have all the buildings now!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Why does it mean to have furniture in her house?
I'll give it to her.
Shop where one can purchase amenities and facilities where
the island has arrived and are short.
Known as Quick build, the shop sells buildings, objects, and
other things necessary for making the island drone.
One resident is quoted as saying, I can go into this
building and buy a whole different building.
If you say so.
Thanks for watching.
Josh boy, welcome back.
Is it just me guys or is it getting hot in here?
It looks like quick build amenities sells all sorts of
things that can be placed around the island.
Go buy a bench like Gengar asked for.
Turn that dream of sitting into a reality.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, you guys already have a job.
Music makes me lose brain cells, I think.
Press X to the launcher.
Oh, Island Builder.
You can place buildings and objects wherever you like using
Island Builder.
Press X Build and select Bench.
Place the bench anywhere you'd like within the highlighted
area.
Oh, it has to be here.
We'll do like right there.
Looking good!
You can always reposition or move the bench later if you
like.
Now please press minus to exit.
My dream bench.
Now I can engage in some high octane relaxing.
Relaxing.
Oh my god, Snake.
What is Snake and Frog Bird doing over there?
Man, three minutes in and I'm already put to work.
on the island.
Oh yeah, did you see how quickly he sat down?
Nice, really nice.
Always good to see a dream come true.
And benches are just the beginning.
Try placing different objects around the island.
Your me's may interact with them in unexpected ways.
You have the power to make the island into a paradise, or a
playground, or a hell.
Whatever feels right for your me's.
However you want the island to look, quick build amenities
is the place to shop for what you need.
And it seems like they have some new inventory already.
Be sure to check it out often.
Oh my gosh already?
Breaking news.
I like how he says keep an eye out for a new face.
I can't understand that he was good.
What is he saying?
Oh my gosh, there...
They're having a whole conversation with just flashlights.
Uh-oh, you guys.
You don't think that they're gonna...
No, not with Frogbrute, please!
No!
We have so many more people to meet!
You have to meet everybody!
You have to meet everyone in the world before you decide on
who you want to be with.
You're not allowed to decide on somebody until...
Quick build amenities.
wishes yeah yeah yeah could you also make iroquois pliskin
she's my favorite mgs character that kojima just forgot
about wait let's see what we can get a conifer tree bro
a traffic light wait there's so many here i think we should
do the um the beach lounger angel ibo took you this news
anchor sounds like an airport announcer speaker the way i
don't understand a lick of what they're saying it's true
wait beach stairs be careful around this tree if it falls it
could take an eye out let's do the lounger but bosom what
else is there to disguise so true wait does YouTube not let
you type a bosom you sound like the T-Rex from the meet the
robins and in other colors I love it.
Beach lounger.
Here's one as a gift.
Okay, let's build it immediately.
Island builder.
Uh, build.
You.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, oops.
What did I ZR?
Oh, there we go.
Just L.
Yes.
Nice.
Let's go shop too and see what else we got.
Wow.
Oh, we're still working here.
We got fences.
Oh, we got guard rails.
Why do we need guard rails?
Superdad seems a bit reserved.
Akashachi, thank you so much for that 10 gift.
Thank you.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Vending machines.
I don't have so much money though.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Weeds!
Flower planter.
Please come again.
Bosom and Prudish are not allowed.
What the heck?
That's so strange.
Nice.
Looks like you're experimenting with the island builder.
You know, Mies will use the items and facilities that you
place on the island all by themselves.
Sometimes you also...
also react when you drop them on top of something.
The quick build amenity sells trees, benches, vending
machines, and more.
How do you think your me's might react to some of those
items?
Well, there's only one way to find out.
Try dropping them on various items and see what happens.
Oh, are you okay?
Uh-oh.
I think Frogbert needs to go potty.
What's wrong?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, he's watching ants!
Did we have... I think...
we have such an issue with ants before a receipt what didn't
they buy wait what he's hungry oh that was it okay snake
wants something yes you want to play a game care for a game
of shadow Yeah, shadow quiz.
Guess what's casting the shadow?
Here's your first mystery shadow.
Okay.
What do you think it is?
TV!
A horror movie?
The answer is...
Horror movie?
Horror movie!
Next, your second mystery shadow.
Got an entire ant form.
What do you think it is?
What?
A cartoon?
answer is guys i think he can only think in boxes and
finally the last mystery he can't he can't think outside the
what do you think it is it's a so so savvy what's ceviche
ceviche the correct answer is
Hey!
Congratulations, you won!
I'm always winning!
Time for your prize!
Let's go big or let's go home!
No, I could have gotten a robot!
Wait, what's the middle thing?
Yeah, baby.
seafood processed with acid wait what's wrong with iBlue
what's wrong with you believe me what's wrong terrible idea
terrible bad idea bad idea look should we take the bite
Um, which one, guys?
Which one do you want to talk about?
Number one?
Number two?
I'm going to adjust the voice after this.
Pick number three, my lord.
It's like Frankenstein trying to talk to me.
Do you feel like talking about the old gay?
You're old gay.
Question for you.
Hi boo.
You can choose between your old gay and a piggy bank.
What do you do?
Uh, uh, um, I guess I get it.
You're old gay.
Really?
Well, if that's the case, we're gonna get along just fine.
You can have money or you can have...
Good friends.
Wait, no, wait, we're doing nicknames?
Minky, Minky, Minky.
Watch him call her mink guy.
Hey, Minky.
No time, no see.
Thank you!
What would I call you guys?
Call Ibu Chat?
So mean.
I hate it.
Chat.
Hey, chat!
It's hard, Miki, and my old friends.
That's too long, babe.
Seems like chat and I are getting along just fine.
It's terrible!
Wait one second though.
I do want to...
I want to change his voice just a little bit.
So that he's a little more easy to understand.
Wait, a voice custom.
There we go.
I think it's the depth.
That's good.
My name is Ibu.
There we go.
You're better now.
I want to know what she says.
Or if he talks.
Oh, another big question.
Another big...
Are you okay?
Um.
Good evening.
What's wrong?
Why aren't you?
It's naked.
I feel like snobbed and I don't see eye to eye.
Do Snuck and I make a great pair.
Oh, no, wait.
Wait, he thinks you're great friends, though.
He thinks you're great friends.
Glad Etto get has brought us together, boss.
Snack.
Oh, absolutely.
Is that right?
Well, I guess I should make more of an effort.
Wow!
Kinda getting along.
This is a study session for a meet and greet?
No!
The bubble blower I got from you is super easy to use.
Big boss!
Oh god, why is he taught?
Do you see his mouth?
It's disgusting.
Save the friendship.
Oh my god.
They're both trying to make... Wait, they're trying to make
a crucial point and failing miserably.
Why is it so steamy?
No, I need to get you out of the situation.
Come here.
I'm going to give you something and you're going to leave,
okay?
I'm going to give you the techno album.
Yeah, she loves it.
Good, good, good.
She leveled up.
Nice.
Wait, I wonder...
she didn't level up so close it sounds like chat is really
into your okay i had so much fun talking to him that we're
friends now you don't say oh good all right the conversation
has ended we're we're fine now wait though has ibo eaten oh
you had an egg but let's get some more stuff welcome it's
true
chose let's buy green curry let's buy pizza let's buy wait
so I still have an egg okay let's buy pizza and buy a butter
cookie let's top water what is the brush up there okay bye
thank you very much don't stop us we were just getting
warmed up no oh what's happening she's on the She hates how
much she loves us.
Yes,
more techno music.
More, more.
Wait, where did Ibu go?
Oh, you're at home?
Why is everybody at home?
A bunch of neats over here.
Hello.
I'm going to give you...
Pizza!
I
feel like pizza fills you up more than just a little bit
like that.
Oh!
Didn't like the fried egg more than the pizza.
Lots of cash!
Thank you!
Thanks for the dono.
Oh, so cute!
You really like that.
What are you?
A quirk, a quirk.
Walks with a swagger.
Rodeo rider.
This is me going to the bathroom.
Fine, if you don't let us love you, then give us lilac.
Walks like a model.
Walks like a robot.
Walk...
No, I love the swagger.
Wagger.
Thanks for the pizza, Minky.
Of course!
Pizza pain!
I feel like I'm getting closer to the right room here.
Good.
Minky has a real passion for a little bit.
I think we're gonna get home on Spooning Week.
Minky!
Minto needs to float.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go, uh...
Maybe I can head pat her and...
Huh.
Howdy.
Yeah.
She really liked that.
Real.
So real.
I want to see her float away.
It's going to look so goofy.
I can't...
It's going to look so scary.
It looks like she's just standing there.
Oh, what are you doing?
Is bored and winsome company?
Come here, come here.
We haven't met yet, have we?
My name is Gengar.
Hello there, Gengar.
I'm known as Mito.
Oh, we're not going to...
Getting familiar.
Sharing fun...
fact about himself as an icebreaker sports show I don't know
I don't know if they're gonna get oh they seem like mind oh
god terrifying
oh oops I'm gonna click on you hey hey see ya bye-bye
Yeah.
That's it.
Get it.
There she goes.
She doesn't even touch the ground.
She's so short she doesn't touch the ground ever.
Imagine being so short you never touch the ground.
Ibu is like having a the time of his afterlife.
Wear and wear clothing.
Hmm.
We were able to make a new person, weren't we?
Let's see.
I will make one last person for today.
Unfortunately.
Who's next?
Someone that you least expect.
At least...
...expect.
I'll explain- I'll say who it is, unless you guys can guess.
Unless you guys can guess, I'll explain who it is at the
end.
It shouldn't take me long to make, actually, I think.
Why is this so him?
Okay.
You can't even see, though, bros.
I wish I could make the hair just a little bit smaller.
Let's see, hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
And then in the back.
We'll go back to these.
I hate it.
I absolutely hate it.
Nemesis, everybody.
Oh, wait.
I was going to give him a beard.
Oh, that's right.
Isn't that honest face?
Wait, why is it like that?
Legitimately.
Why is it like that?
Oh, his mustache is like...
Okay, hold on.
What does this do?
Oh, wow.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Why does he have a neckbeard?
How do I change it?
Why does he have a neckbeard for...
Why are all the options neckbeard?
What?
This is...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe we get rid of...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
No!
It's so terrible!
We'll get rid of...
What is this?
What does that do?
What?
Might have to draw the beard.
I'm baffled as to why you're making him.
Because we need enemies on the island.
We need enemies.
I mean, we could take away this beard.
We could just give him a mustache.
And take this away.
Hot dog.
Not hot dog moment.
So proud of you for facing your fears.
Thank you.
We could make him look like this.
It's actually the worst thing.
I'm having to look at photos of him.
I want to cry!
We might have to paint on the beard.
I think we'll have to paint on the beard.
Who are you making?
His name is Haley Joel Osmond.
He's my enemy.
Let me redo that.
Yeah, good enough.
Good enough.
Yeah, good enough, good enough.
Great start.
And finish!
Why is Frogbert doing that?
He's doing way too much.
Oh, you guys are dancing!
Look at you!
End scene.
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, no, I pressed...
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I pressed X instead.
Not bad.
She hates Sora.
It's my body.
Instinctively telling me to stop it.
It's not too late.
My name is Haley.
Joel Osmond.
Oh,
when's his birthday?
April 10th?
We just missed it.
April 10th.
1988.
Says he's 38 years old.
There we go.
We'll do it like a little bit.
My name is Haley Joel Osment.
My name is Haley Joel.
Oh, that sounds like Sora.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Haley Joel Osmond.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 20th, 2026.
So...
Stop talking.
No.
His movement is slow.
His speech is whatever.
His energy is flat.
He's probably actually probably a chill guy.
But we'll go serious.
Overall, he's normal.
We gotta make him into everybody too though.
Aloof, logical, tenacious, cautious.
Speaks matter-of-factly.
He's a perfectionist, imaginative and inspired.
Happiest when creating something.
Finds beauty in everyone and everyone.
every oh good he's been exiled I think we're safe um oh um
nice to meet you I'm Haley Joel Osmond I'm a reserved
perfectionist I'm serious particular and pretty clever
that's something a narcissist would say so myself yeah you
narcissist I'm looking forward to living here
falls for him that might be the way that might just be the
way uh oh a house is basically an island of the house is
basically an island of its own he won't be able to leave if
he stays this way good add some landscaping to connect the
main island to the land around his home the island builder
build let's start with some grass why does haley joel
osman's personality description Loki sound like a serial
killer because he is more see let's start with some grass
fine since this is your first time a location has already
been chosen for you please fill in the highlighted area okay
oh the whole thing okay perfect the land is connected now
please press the exit minus to exit There we go.
Oh, disgusting.
Oh my god.
With the land connected, he can go other places and meet
people.
Ew, he's on the move!
I wanted to keep him in Alcatraz!
You can transform the layout of your island in many ways,
including building new land where the sea used to be.
This can help you connect areas together or make rooms as
needed.
Hey, if you make the island bigger, it seems like plenty of
mees could live here.
steak we interrupt to bring you some breaking news yeah
here's what's happening on our island come on come on yay
get strung your own welcome back away he looks disgusting
standing there meaning anyone can land upon our humble
shores anytime residents are overjoyed at the news calling
in to say finally a fresh audience and our numbers will soon
be multitudinous multitudinous there will be no stopping us
our might will be infinite yes thanks for watching watching
i'm snake and you're up to date thank you snake sometimes
mees can get married or become All of your mees are living
by themselves right now, but it makes sense that mees who
get married or become great friends might want to live
together in a bigger house.
You can help foster these kinds of relationships by helping
your mees interact with each other.
Give it a try!
Is he asleep?
Oh no, he's just chilling.
What's up?
Oh, he's frozen!
Oh, bring someone!
Oh!
Haley, Joel Osment!
Gah.
Gah!
Wait, big boss, another quick tip for you.
I don't feel like you have to drag a me halfway across the
island just to talk to another specific me.
Well, there's an easier way.
Grab the me you want, press Y.
Open up the me.
It feels so nice.
Bring them both together immediately.
Oh, wow!
Am I interrupting something?
I just can't.
Oh my god, he's right behind you.
Oh my god, it's terrifying.
So first I do this, then this.
Oh, I think you're on to something.
What is he doing to you?
No.
No!
What kind of eyes?
Haley Joel Osmond.
Even his name is lovely.
Immediately.
Oh, Haley Joel Osmond.
at
first sight
it might be the worst thing ever it must be love so this is
love i'm gonna eat some crackers i i want to start dating
haley joel osman and live happily ever after oh what you
just moved because
the law i get it you just moved as a man.
Literal first inter- Did he just run away?
Literal first interaction with anyone on the island, too.
Hey, Big Boss, a quick word about relationships.
The means that live on your island will naturally develop
feelings for each other and even begin relationships.
Kids can become besties with kids and adults can have
romantic flings or even get married to adults.
They may need your advice in these matters.
Are you okay?
Good evening.
So, I guess I like Haley Joel Osmond.
Ghosts love Haley Joel Osmond because he makes them feel
seen.
He actually, like, ran away, though.
He ran, like, I saw his shadow, like, book it.
Minto in third place.
I want to eat something you made.
with your own hands.
Without my own hand?
It seems like you want to eat something you prepared.
Okay.
Wow.
That's asking a lot of me.
Palette house.
You can craft your own original clothing, food, and other
items.
Wait, what?
All you have to do is find a place for it.
Where should it go?
Um.
Here?
Oh, we need to start making more room on the island.
Poisoning coming.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A Palette House workshop has opened on Yen.
You want to be the same height as Chikawa?
Yeah!
Welcome back, away toland Ciderone.
At the local Palette House, Big Boss can make all sorts of
things for residents, like food and clothing.
Wait, this is huge!
It's about time.
And can you make me an edible tuxedo?
Thanks for watching.
I'm Crawford, and you're up to date.
Oh my god!
Here in the Palo Workshop, you can make different creations
by drawing pictures.
Now we're ready to make some food.
Try creating something you think your means would love to
eat.
Why not make your first creation a piece of cake?
We started it for you since it's your first one.
So all that's left for you is to give the cake its tasty
finishing touches.
If you prefer not to draw, try using the stamps.
Wait, what are the stamps?
Is it these?
Oh, wow!
Wait, what?
Wait, ew, ew.
Eww!
What is this?
Wait!
Oh!
No way!
Turn this picture into a statue.
Oh, whoops.
I don't want to make it.
Oh.
If you love yourself so much, you would eat yourself.
Make him eat his first crush.
No, this is...
Wow.
This is for Haley Joel Osman.
It's not for Gengar.
Oh, whoops.
Wait, I didn't mean to do another one.
Delete, delete.
Yeah, we'll delete that one too.
It's like cat ears.
But of himself.
I'm gonna draw.
Thank you.
Oh,
that was supposed to be a fly.
All right, we're done.
Cakey.
Joel Osmond.
Is this your way of hinting that...
It's...
Don't...
Don't make it...
Don't shorten his name.
It's the third content.
I just opened this stream.
What the heck?
So excited for...
Joel Osmond to carry a healthy baby ghastly.
It's the cakey Joel Osmond.
Okay.
Cakey Joalashit.
Yes.
Oily.
Type?
A beverage.
Temperature?
Cold.
Actually, no.
What in the seven hells is that?
Oh, is that the custom food means you can make alz...
Pizza for a house.
Pizza Palace.
The finest pizza pizza in all of London.
It's the cakey jollas shit.
I don't want to gift it to anybody else.
Why did I have to go buy it?
It cost me $5!
Thank you very much.
This is your finest work.
There you go.
He drank it.
Could you make me something different next time?
Dang, he paid well, though.
Whoa, he ate it.
Now you have the ability to create new types of food.
Wait, that's huge.
He hated it.
By the way, if you have any friends nearby, Oh, thanks.
I have no friends nearby.
What are you doing?
If only someone else would join me.
Let's get...
Here.
Come on out.
Leave your house.
You gotta go meet somebody.
What is he doing?
Come on.
Oh, hello.
to meet you.
My name is Haley Joel Osment.
Hello there.
Haley Joel Osment.
I'm known as Snake.
Oh, getting familiar.
Excitially telling a story that to be perfectly honest,
really isn't all that interesting.
God, that's so like him, isn't it?
Oh, they like each other though.
See him, how, I wanna see ones like immediately don't like
each other you know what I mean I need I mean so what is
happening here having their minds minds blown by the
unexpected ways this techno album develops wait what's going
on here gang already you just met the guy my heart hurts
I may not know Haley Joel Osmond very well, but I know fate
has big plans for us.
What should I do?
What do you want to do?
Follow your heart, Gengar.
What do I want to do?
Well, it's so rare someone asks me that.
Let me think.
Hum.
I've got...
my answer I want to be friends first go for it what should
we talk about other lingo oh I know I know I know I know
wait I can't write something wait hold on oh let's see what
did you have in mind I know I know I know a thing is no no
no It's...
Let's see.
Hold on, hold on.
What did you have in mind?
Is it something else?
Oh yeah, okay, cool, cool.
The door
to darkness.
The door to darkness?
Yes.
Got it.
I'll go talk to him about the door to darkness.
Does he like it?
The door to darkness?
Good evening.
Haley Joel Osmond.
He turned around so fast.
Do you feel like talking about...
The door to darkness?
Tell me, Gengar.
Did you see that report on TV yesterday?
The one about the door to darkness?
They're just reporting on the news?
Of course I saw it.
I've been itching to talk to someone about it.
I was fascinated.
Plus, I've been wanting to talk with someone about the door
to darkness.
He knows a lot about it.
So, let's be friends, and then we can talk about it.
Why is it on the TV?
I like how they bow at each other.
Good thing you can see ghosts, right?
I want to see them kiss.
Why are they staring at me?
Good friends.
Gengar will call Haley Joel Osman.
Baby.
Hey baby.
Oh whoops.
Haley baby.
Sora!
Pookie aging.
Whoops, so much.
Joe!
You look great today.
What will Gengar's nickname?
Wait, this is literally a Pokemon question.
Joe!
Wait, and then Gengar can be... Oh.
Good evening.
No, no, no, no.
Gengar, can be joe joe how goes it okay looks like joe and i
are friends thanks to the door to darkness seems like i can
have a fun chat with joe
good job joe and joe
It's blushing so much.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's going on here?
Oh, we have two.
Frogbert!
Has a dilemma.
Huh?
Good evening.
Very bizarre.
I think Iroquois is a fascinating person.
But I'm wondering, do Iroquois and I make a great pair?
Absolutely.
After a 30 minute run to cleanse my soul of what I've seen,
I'm glad to come back to a pure say-so stream.
So, you know, Joe can see dead people and Ibu is a ghost
type too, so does that...
Our island is filled with ghosts, actually.
Snake, there is only him and Joe on the island?
No?
Oh, well.
I hope you're right.
I could totally see us getting closer.
He sees you as food.
Great friends!
But it's one-sided.
Don't just decide that on your own, maybe.
Frogbird's a ghost too?
No, but, you know, like...
Alright, let's go do our well because it's like super
overflowing.
They're still talking.
Let's fill up our well, baby!
Go, go, go!
Yeah, we need a...
Whoa!
Level 6!
Nice.
Oh!
Island Builder.
New wishes are available.
Who's the wishes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Sand!
Let's get some new gifts, maybe.
A cat?
The bosoms.
Wisdom photography.
Bosom photography!
Alright, what is what's in the pallet house?
Clothing!
Oh no!
Wait, this is too, this is scary.
What else do we have for goods?
Oh, nothing.
Street Dancing 101.
That seems kind of fun.
I don't have any- oh wait, eating styles!
Oh, not because I level 10.
No!
I want the eating styles.
Hmm.
We can also do the doggy dog world.
Road sign.
there's too many new things too many things let's do
treasures eventually we get to unlock everything so nice
what do you want what do you want what do you want huh leave
me alone hey how about a game of zoom quiz okay let's play
here's item what do you think it is hot dog
i didn't expect to see the name in the wild so no way hot
dog the answer is hot dog next your second zoomed in item
what do you think it is
Children's album!
The answer is...
Children's album.
And finally, the last doomed in item.
What do you think it is?
I don't know.
Mint candy?
What is this?
The correct answer is...
Mint candy.
Congratulations.
You won.
Time for your prize.
I can't do it anymore.
Go ahead.
I can't.
Oh, who was online?
I don't even know.
Sorry, I didn't see.
I got a circuit board!
We could have gotten a frog!
He knows!
Give it to a meal, but selling it could also give your
wallet a bit boost.
Find a buyer.
Right price pawn shop.
Wait, I have no space.
Holy cow!
This place is humongous!
Alright.
there we go oh okay nice oh is that a threat oh it's amity
here's what's happening on island a very reputable pawn shop
has opened on yay get strunger own welcome back away tome
insider you'll want to visit the right price to sell off any
treasure, you don't need any more.
Locals are responding to the news with, Will they buy my
pocket lint?
And I was told this treasure is priceless.
But the cashier sure was glad to put a price tag on it.
Thanks for watching.
Very reputable.
I'm Gengar, and you're up to date.
Thanks, Gengar.
His eyes get a little wonky there.
They're hanging out.
how unique the Techno album is.
Good, good, good.
Are you jealous?
Oh, you're bored?
Okay.
You guys can meet now?
Everybody loves Techno.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Haley Joel Osmond.
Haley Joel Osmond.
Hello.
You guys think it's Love is First Sight, too?
They're talking about the door to darkness!
I hope they don't get along.
Nah!
I want to see two that don't get along.
I want to see some that don't seem like-minded.
Now I'm close to Ibu.
And it's all thanks to you, big boss.
Wait, he has a crush on Gengar too?
Wait a second.
What?
Snake, are you okay?
Yeah, I want to fight.
Um?
Good evening.
What's wrong?
I want to try living with Gongaga.
I forgot his name was Gongaga.
I was like, who the hell are you talking about?
If I lived with Gongaga, we'd be spending a lot of time.
much though uh-oh what's something you think we'd enjoy
doing every day if gongaga and i live together
i think you're right i'll go talk to him can i have a word
i'm worried this is not gonna go well sure what's up snake
loves together what's something you think we'd enjoy doing
every day wet t-shirt contest let's say it together on three
one two three wet t-shirt contest turns
out we're not on the same page i don't think living together
is a good Oh, no, I'm sorry.
Do you ever visit the right price pawn shop?
They'll buy treasures you don't want or need.
I thought everybody would be into a wet t-shirt contest.
Cash.
Let's give him a little bit of a head pat.
Let's give him a head pat.
You poor guy.
No.
But he leveled up.
Wait!
Can we do a phrase now?
Expression.
Shouted at the sea.
Wait.
H-N-N-G-H.
Okay, how do we say it?
Okay, hold on.
H-N-N-G-H.
N-N-G-A-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-N-G-H-E-R-N-G-H-E-R-N-G
Wait, hold on, her,
her, and then like, uh,
I guess maybe hung.
Yeah, I guess that works.
H-U-N-G-G-G No!
H-U-N-G-G-G-G H-U-N-G-G-G
Uh...
Yeah, let's try like...
H-H-H-H-H-W-H-W...
Wait, uh...
H-N-G...
I think that's the closest we can get.
Heng-o.
Thank you.
Saying that really makes me feel more like myself.
It is.
It is like you.
Heng-o.
I thought it'd be fun to live with Gangaka.
But maybe now isn't the right time.
I'm sorry.
I knew it wasn't gonna go well.
That's not hearts, right?
Okay.
Telling nostalgic stories about the magic of their first...
First love?
No, I can't watch this.
That's Frogbert.
Oh no!
I'll bring someone.
Uh...
What?
Are you alive?
Now they can meet.
I've never seen a case this bad before.
I love the way you say it.
I'm gonna be okay though.
Right?
We should have cased this bar before.
Thank you.
She's meddling.
Now they're friends.
Don't you want to be friends with Frogbird?
That's your real Oshi, no?
What if you fall for Frogbird?
All right, let's go check out this pawn shop.
Nice seeing you here.
Oh, we can sell our fishing lure for a good amount.
sitting on a bench telling me though my first love the very
first vtuber annoying orange our circuit board the skeleton
of electronic devices what would our world be without them a
lightweight kettle for all your water boiling needs
symbolizes gratitude and love for the maternal presence in
your life the more you try separating them forbidden romance
is pretty enticing no I'm deleting my game.
We can't have this happen!
Watch, in every lifetime, in any life iteration, you guys...
You guys would fall for Minto, probably.
What is happening down here?
Do we let it happen?
Oh!
Get away from me.
Could I have a moment?
Ew, why are you so close to me?
I'm Haley Joel Osmond.
I forgot she floats.
They seem to be having a laid-back chat.
Okay.
That's fine, I suppose.
For now.
Hengar, what's wrong?
Wait, what is this?
So, truth is, I've always loved you.
Choo!
Oh!
Um, I had a feeling that was the case.
So you saw right through me?
Something like that.
Why don't we give a data shot?
Really?
I'd love to.
Just lool.
Oh,
he's gonna go do it.
Nope, never mind, he's posing.
That was disturbing.
Go get him, Gengar.
He totally stripped his face.
What are some of the new things that are here?
Oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Please come again.
And then this.
Oh, yeah, we can make a treasure.
That's right.
A pet!
From here you can create pets for me's!
What pet do you think they'd like?
Blank canvas or template.
Prior creation.
Wait!
What should I make?
We'll make an actual eye blue.
Sorry.
Kind of looks like a duck.
I'm going to first try this.
I'm going to first try.
this.
Don't you worry.
It'll look awesome.
First try.
Oh wait, that's fine.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine, don't worry about it.
That's fine, that's fine.
Don't
worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Coming together.
First try.
Make a diamond dog.
Huey.
Thanks for the super chat.
Sorry, I'm trying to draw your eye.
I guess that works.
Why can't I draw a circle?
There's just something about him that looks a little angry
though.
What is it?
Why are you mad?
There you go!
Ibu.
Ibu but not sentient.
Well, yeah, sentient.
Ibu.
Hey boo.
Let's do it.
Let's fix it again.
The pronunciation?
Ibu.
What if I snuck a little extra B in there?
Hi boob.
Secret.
Trait.
Chart.
Fascinating.
Wait, funny, funny, funny, funny.
You guys are so funny.
I think floating suits it, but I think something else would
be funnier.
Like crawling.
Sound?
What does this pet sound like?
Ew.
This sounds like it's farting.
Oh my god, so cute.
Yeah, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
So cute!
Oh, my big boss's treasure shop!
What?
I have a treasure shop?
My treasures.
You are my treasure.
Me too?
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on your island.
It's so awesome, we're going to crawl around.
A new store called My Treasures has opened on Ye.
Strangerone.
Welcome back, away tomenciderone.
It's being reported that this store sells treasures that
were crafted at a pallet house workshop.
Residents are elated, calling in to make cash register sound
effects and saying, what shimmering riches await us.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Haley Joel Osmond, and you're up to date.
Haley, I'm sorry I was checking something on my phone.
can give me is handmade treasures i bet they'll appreciate
anything you make for them all right let's go make it
welcome you guys you guys cost only one five dollars
why did you avoid the empty lot this one because a house
will go there duh wait come here right here i'm giving you
something do you need me yes I'm giving you something.
A treasure.
Where is he?
Oh, here it is.
Yay!
She loves it!
Me, if he!
Thank you for super tight!
I'm always worried about offending someone.
Where's your pet?
Oh!
No way, is he looking at...
Okay, no, I thought he was.
Blue?
It's
so...
It's unreal.
How good this is.
Blue?
Oh, well.
Oh, my God.
It's steamy over there.
It's steamy.
What are they talking about?
They're disgusting exotic types of kids.
Do you think Gengar would like it?
We could give it to him.
The Kiki Jolau shit?
Let's buy it.
We're deformed, stripped of agency, but happy.
No, it's perfect.
It's perfect.
You've outdone yourself again, Minto.
Thank you.
All right, here we go.
Why are you acting cute on the bench like that?
Stop it.
The music is so like...
Yum.
He didn't like it at all.
I don't think anybody will like this ever.
What are you doing?
Stop that.
Why are you so annoying?
Are you bored?
I can't get over this, though.
It's so...
It's such a good little pet.
Hello, big lovers.
Today.
What the hell?
If only someone else would join me.
Oh, if only someone else would join me.
As he stares at me.
Anybody else want to do some aerobics?
Hello?
Anyone?
Does anyone else want to do some aerobics?
Does anyone want to?
Oh, they're listening to more techno.
Go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
crying.
It's so funny.
He just wants to play with me, though.
She wouldn't even give him the simple time of day.
I feel like Frog Bird is lonely.
And also maybe stepped in some poo.
Left by you guys.
She hates us.
Wait, do you think 3 is a company?
Or 3 is a crowd?
Let's see it.
Chop missed me though.
Oh no, I can't.
Typical behavior.
Oh, they're strangers.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Frogbert.
You're Frogbert.
I'm Haley Joel Osmond.
Let's see.
Frogbert is reporting that he spotted a cloud that looked
just like a beautiful pod.
Oh wait, I forgot I got a camera.
Oh,
imagine daydream.
Wait, we could give it to Snake too.
They both had the same dream.
Where is Snake's home?
Wait, Snake has moroccas.
I don't think Frogbert has it.
any item so we'll give frogbert the we'll give we'll give
frogbert the camera it's so
it's actually so funny wait where's the camera
wait where is it i did unlock it didn't i oh it's a level up
item oh We'll give him something to eat and then he'll...
Oh, whoops.
He'll level up.
Here's some green curry.
Yum.
Look at you in the background.
Oh, he hated it, never mind.
That's so mean.
It is, it is, it is.
It's so you.
I will not give you the cake.
Yum.
I don't
like it more.
Maybe we can give the kettle too.
I just want him to level up.
Level up right now.
We'll give you the roses too because that's very you.
The next cloud reminds him of Haley Jula's cake.
Wait, why are you naked now?
Why are you in your box?
Why?
I love the way that I fool walks around.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Why are you in your boxers?
Increased stealth.
Oh, got it, got it.
I want to see him use it right away.
Oh, it's...
Minto's asleep!
Ooh, that's what I think I have sleep apnea.
Hey, listen to this.
You'll grow taller if I water you, right?
Oh, hey, listen to this.
Everyone will believe me when I say you and I talk, right?
Hey, listen to this.
The other day, a snake whores something with the price tag
still attached.
Aw, what a loser.
Hey, listen to this.
You must be pretty good at tongue twisters.
Hey, that's the whole dream.
Guess it was just a dream.
I got a light bulb.
Thanks, Minto.
Wait, I wonder if I can give you a new room.
Oh, renovate.
Here we go.
The interior.
The entire room.
Oh.
Oh, my god.
My eyes is a...
Oh, it's a hit!
She loves it!
We're raking up the cash, too.
Thank you.
Oh, my god, my eyes.
Get me out of this room.
Oh, God.
Get me out of this room!
we can put some stuff in the fountain she loves the riding
room yippee level seven let's do
there are no cars on the island but there's a traffic light
just in case wait that might be kind of fun let's do the
traffic light
nice and then hi but what's wrong what's wrong good evening
yeah i've been thinking too hard my head feels all fuzzy
inside it reminds me of that one roof don't keep shooting
what are you thinking of I need to rewind my...
Oh, shoot, shoot.
Oh, I got it!
Is that kimchi?
I feel...
I feel so much better now.
Is that good of kimchi?
Oh, hope you enjoy your kimchi.
You wanna try it?
You think you wanna eat it?
Kimchi brained.
This is the kimchi that came out of your brain.
Here you go.
Yo!
So we could have gotten crabs.
I just liked it.
Nice.
Yes, give me more.
Give me more.
Nice.
Hmm.
What are you taking photos of?
Wow.
Does eating one's own kimchi brain worms count as
cannibalism?
Not really not.
What's this guy doing?
He's begging me.
No.
I hope this money is helpful.
Oh god, I hate that you're nice in this game.
Wait, who's over?
They're hanging out!
They're saying they're so scared of weak looking ala- Wait,
what?
What's up?
Wait, what's up with Gengar?
Wait, what do you mean?
by all of that logo clare what do you mean tram tram is the
champ oh flacky printer oh he traveled the channel with him
in printer wait what's happening shut up
what i feel all mixed up no i like joe but i also have
feelings for snob who do you think i I really like.
I don't know!
What?
You never forget your first.
No, but Snake has been with you from the beginning.
Gengar's a playboy.
I think Gengar just yearns for a relationship.
I think it's gotta be Snark.
I feel my love for Joe is dying down.
I think I like Snark.
I think I like...
But you rejected him!
from staying together.
Minto missed her shot.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait, with Snake.
Oh, no.
Just good friends.
It was kind of getting along.
What happened?
What happened to her?
What?
He's a yearner.
So I said, happen.
Blue, partly snow prince.
Gamble.
But what if Snake, like, rejects him?
Thanks for everything you've done to make this island
wonderful so far.
Seems like the mees that live here are getting used to the
island line.
Did you know that they get up to stuff?
Even when you're not watching, wish you could get some kind
of daily report on...
Well, perhaps an MNN news station is in order.
Once you build one, you can get all kinds of fun reports
about your Mia's daily lives.
Okay, fine.
I guess we're gonna build it right here.
I didn't want to get rid of our bushes, but...
over there.
Wait.
Actually, I wonder if we could build it right behind this
house and it would cause so much trouble.
It would be so, like, loud and annoying.
You can place on concrete.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
He mocks you by making everyone on the island fall in love
with him and throwing money in your phone like you're a
charity gaze.
You're right!
Get strong, Jerome.
Welcome back away, Wait, the roadside roll.
The MNN News Station is now fully operational.
The dulcet tones of island residents will deliver the
island's hottest topics once a day.
Hotest topics.
Stop by MNN Daily to make sure you don't miss a single
story.
I love the news, I love the news.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks, Frogbert.
I'm Frogbert, and you're up to date.
Thank you.
Wait, what concrete?
Oh, this one right here!
I can still move it.
Let's see.
Island builder.
I can move it right there.
There we go.
That looks better.
I completely missed it with my eyes.
Anyway.
What's going on in here?
Yeah, where is all the previous news coming from?
for April 20th, 2026.
Folks, we have an underdog story to report today.
Huh?
Haley Joel Osmond has been working out lately and really
getting into it.
In fact, he was scheduled for leg day today.
But shockingly, he simply decided to not do it.
Reached for comment, Haley Joel Osmond told reporters that
his lazy side won out.
Uh-huh.
It's like a voice in my head was telling me to stay in bed.
He said.
We asked residents for their reactions.
Feels like they got me.
I told you so.
So true.
Thanks for watching.
I told you so too.
I'm Gengar.
And this has been the 10 o'clock news.
We're the devil's on his shoulder.
Have you been enjoying the mean news broadcast?
Did you know that you can replay your favorites?
queue up old favorites anytime at the news station but as
more stories break the older ones will eventually be
de-listed be sure to lock anyone you can lock up to 49
stories okay the ones that we like the mostest he's blushing
you're in his house only only frogbert is still out on the
town he appreciates the beauty of night it's quite difficult
filming in low light though Oh, Minto's asleep.
I guess that's my cue too.
Oh, Gengar's also leaving.
And they're still about the elastic.
He's on the prowl.
Oh, wait!
Oh!
Everyone's going home!
Are you okay?
Oh.
He was all blushy, blushy.
Yeah, Snake loves the elastic.
He really does.
Are you going home?
Oh, no, they're out.
Wait.
Frogbert has a dilemma.
One thing I like about this game is I feel with the
original, like, when it got later in the night, you really
couldn't do much, you know?
Can I ask you something personal about I-boo?
Do you think I-boo and I would make a good team?
Yes, absolutely.
Is that so?
Huh?
I never thought about him that way before, but now I'm
curious.
past 10 p.m there's really like nothing to do right
uh spring it's even a refreshing name why don't you have
clothes on i'm very curious why it took off his clothes oh
wait what's happening here wait they both want my attention
what what is it Um.
Um.
All right, we'll do these and then...
Feeling sharp.
Wanna play no repeats with a group of folks.
Group of...
Are you sure?
You took them off?
When it's your turn, pick the name of a food.
The game ends if someone picks something that isn't a food.
Or is too slow to answer or repeats a food.
Oh.
No repeats.
Food.
Macadamia nuts.
Red chili pepper.
Clap, clap.
Kew don't.
Soft serve ice cream Clop, clop What?
It's a game?
Cremberle Fried plantains Gingerbread Omelet Salmon moinier
Macadamian You lose, you stupid Yeah Yeah
Congratulations, you won!
What a dummy!
What do we get?
Let's go for a small prize this time.
I got a sugar glider!
I got a whole ass squirrel in there!
Let's go.
All right.
Snark!
What's up?
up oh he can't stop hiccuping i'll bring someone this game
is genuinely so addicting every time oh i know right
every time i want to wrap things up i think but maybe it's
because they like they like literally oh whoops whoops wait
hey bring minto but minto's asleep we can try um wake up
what it's because there's always like a little me that's
Wait a second!
What's up?
I have a thing!
Oh.
That's just like the original.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no!
Come here.
You have to help, Snake.
Are you in trouble?
Please, Hick, help me!
Hick.
Please, Hick.
There's the source of the problem.
Um, you might need to use a little more of...
This is a real vision in the Minto's actual tummy.
I am hungry.
No.
I never really noticed Minto before.
But now I can't get her face out of my mind.
I hope she looks at me and smiles.
No!
And I fall in love with Minto.
It must be love.
I looked into Minto's gentle eyes and fell back.
I am madly in love.
Oh, I can imagine us together.
I can gaze into those eyes every day.
I always wanted you to say those every day.
This is so messy.
Wait, you're right.
me me after he falls and like oh then i got below my nose
i love going into my plain white room and listening to
techno for two seconds and then leaving i'm sorry i boobs we
may be doomed
what happened
You almost gave the opportunity to Gengar.
Ew, don't talk to him.
No!
Some Mies.
Oh, he's walking by with his swagger.
No way.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Mies are gathering.
They're venting about their biggest pet peeves of 2026.
Oh, my God.
You said something scandalous.
the power move.
Literally walking right in between them.
Are you guys okay?
You're venting a lot.
But you just started.
No, it didn't.
It's almost May.
It's almost halfway through the year.
Can you believe that?
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Guys.
Hey, good evening.
Uh-oh.
I think he wants to confess.
It may just be my imagination, but I get the feeling that
Snop has a crush on me.
Uh-oh.
You sure?
Ask for a date.
I could say you sure about that, though.
January was last week.
ask for a date yeah maybe i will if we both feel the same
way it only makes sense right go for that oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh he's serious oh he's serious
even my I don't even have a heart and I'm just beating oh
knock it seems your love for me is more than you can bear
what other choice do i have wait a second where'd this
confidence come from i'll let you go out with me oh geez i'm
sorry but the answer's new
things uh makes it a ghost was it all just a big
misunderstanding it's like i'm Kim on the date!
Put the punchline to every joke is my life.
Oh my days.
Has some hope!
Sadness!
Snop shot me down.
Have something for you.
Uh, a kettle.
Oh wait, some carnations.
Snake has a crush on Minto.
I guess he's a ghost eater.
No, he is a ghost babble.
What the hell?
You don't like flowers?
Not sure if it's a good match.
The worst he can truly say is no.
Snatch up.
He did have something for you.
I have something for you.
Let's give you a cookie.
You want a cookie?
You want a little cookie?
Sigh.
Don't sigh.
I love how on my island there's mini my minis are yapping
about Yuri and Yowie and there's this what do you mean
there's this what do you mean there's this this is the best
thing that could be how about I give you a kettle
It's heartbroken cut him some slack Oof Oof he's uh Oh oops
You want a light bulb?
I'm running out of stuff to give you.
I gave him a light bulb.
The music is so sad.
Oh my god, he doesn't like that either!
He can still have Joe.
They're Joe and Joe!
He can still like Joe.
Oh my gosh.
You want some clothes?
We got...
A dinosaur hood.
Or does he want some sexy ribbon tights?
I was gonna give these to Koharu, but, um, or Ocelot, but
here you go.
Your Mies are looking as fashionable as ever.
But did you know your Mies will hang onto clothing you give
them even when they switch outfits?
So if you want them to change into something you give them
before, just press Y.
Oh, nice.
Slay, slay.
Oh, whoops.
We'll just have to let him, like...
We'll just let him, you know...
Uh...
Let him...
Handle it.
Yeah, he needs time.
We gave him all we could do.
What are you doing over here?
No.
Only for me.
No, you don't get one.
Look at the little apple in the window.
You guys, he's a treasure.
He's a treasure.
And thus begins Gengar's training redemption arc to become
Sun Jin Gengar.
No!
He's fine just the way he is.
Oh, gosh.
Snop, you're such a meanie.
I loved you so much.
I can't believe you.
Maybe if you get his name right.
Oh my gosh.
The eyeball walking around in the background.
Am I not good enough for you?
Not even one care in the world.
Snop.
Am I not good enough for you?
Snuck!
Snuck.
Am I not good enough for you?
So cute.
The people yearn for the concert hall!
He's too cool.
Oh!
He was checking Minto out, but was trying to be casual about
it and was like, no, there's something on my shoe.
The walk is too good.
What was that?
Stepped in some ectoplasm.
Yeah, oh, I think she donated.
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes.
Okay, guys, now I think I'll actually call it here.
Um, gosh.
Wait, where are you going?
Oh, I thought you were going to Frogbird's house.
Are you just laughing all by yourself?
What's wrong?
What are you doing?
Oh.
Okay.
This was a perfect ending.
Poor Gengar will be a little sad until we see him next.
Ibu's bored.
Oh, wait, what's happening?
Nice to see you.
Wait, what's happening?
No.
I thought I'd share this with you.
Oh, perfect timing.
I have something for you too.
Oh, it looks too expensive.
Try Princess, thank you.
I have something for you.
A bunch more gifted to me.
Say.
Oh.
No, I have too many of these as it is.
You'd be doing me a favor by taking it.
Mentions.
I'll take it.
Oh, they don't even hang.
Okay, I was going to say they don't even hang out.
Yay!
What are they talking about?
Randomly laughing about some Bogogi.
I'm with you.
I feel like the sky's the limit.
his house too cute i love little ibu pet i wanna i want him
i want to take him home he's so cute he's so cute
thank you guys again for coming to you live we have we have
another stream in a couple days as well so we will make
gangard feel better and maybe some lobby developments how
about adding in Yasha for a Minto love triangle.
You did it, Minto!
I didn't know you could win this game, but good job, Bossu.
Look at you, living the life.
Good night.
Also, Aibu, next time, you've got to up your game!
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie,
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie Minkie Minkie.
fan art I don't know if anybody has any advice for a fan is
not showing up in the hashtag.
Hmm.
Show the relationship chart.
How do I show the...
Oh, is there like a chart chart?
Hmm.
Make a second account to tag it.
Other account or not?
Unfortunately, no.
Twitter might put shadow ban on new accounts?
I don't know how to say shadow ban in Japanese.
Some other fans that like it become more visible.
Discord, I don't care about you.
I don't care if you're taking a stroll.
Okay!
What are you doing?
Oh my gosh, I can't stop playing this game.
He's like topping the water.
Oh wait!
Oh yeah, Gengar's still sad.
That's right.
But thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And I will see you!
Next time!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Thank you.